[Music]
hey hey
party people
big ups to hill mount high we started at
the upper middle
and now we're here but for tonight me
casa
i mean you know how the rest of that
goes whoa we gotta live forever
[Applause]
how did this all go so wrong
[Applause]
pop star actor and celebrity
humanitarian xavier was found dead
tonight
his body discovered on the cliff during
an after party for his high school
reunion
this
is a murder
any one of you could be the murderer
and i want to hear your story the same
thing could happen but you see it in a
different way
i want to hear your mind moving
did you see her hair it looks like she
made out with a tornado it's just jewish
hair so much volume
my goal is to find out who killed xavier
now you all went to your high school
reunion
for what second chances at life
love
something else
i would just love it if you could just
skip to the part where the murder
happened i'm telling you a story here
i'm building character arcs dynamics
everybody here hated xavier he is the
worst i'm gonna have sex with your ex
dude
six years old daddy i love him
everyone seems to think you did it
everyone
it's all anyone's talking about
sorry you're you that's not fun
any one of us could snap what who oh
you want to confess to a murderer but we
need to know who killed him tonight bam
everybody seems to be hiding something
what is going on
we're down here yeah but you didn't even
know that was fake and you straight up
just chopped off his head remember that
[Music]
you